hey guys it's vadim with max tech and
i'm extremely excited because
john prosser was able to get his hands
on an actual
image of the unreleased redesigned
macbook air
so he worked with ian's elbow on twitter
to create some new renders
which are absolutely mind-blowing we've
got white bezels
a white keyboard new colors that
basically match the ones from the new
imac
and a completely flat design and to be
honest
it looks great in every single way but
the point of this video is that from
those renders and the details that john
gave us
we can actually pull a lot of new
information including some of the specs
the chip that's going into it the actual
name
and more importantly the release date of
this new macbook
so let's get right into it starting off
with the design the new keyboard is now
white
which makes total sense because the
bezels are now confirmed to be white
by john prosser but going even deeper
the new imax keyboard is white
like it's always been and apple has just
released a new
white magic keyboard case for the ipad
pro
so it shouldn't be surprising that we're
now getting a super
clean looking white keyboard now i know
that a lot of you guys complained about
the white keyboard getting very dirty
but you need to know that the keys on
even the current macbooks
already have special coatings on them to
resist
fingerprints so i don't think it's going
to be that big of a deal and i also love
that little detail on ian's renders that
shows that the touch id button
will literally match the one that's on
the new imax keyboard
which shows apple's focus on design
consistency
that same consistency is why we're now
getting the white bezels
just like we got on the imac especially
since we're expecting
the same exact colors as we're getting
with the imac so in my opinion
white bezels on this macbook are gonna
look really really nice
especially in person and they'll make
this apple silicon macbook
easily recognizable compared to every
other macbook out there but the big
thing that i want to talk about is the
actual
thickness of this macbook which is going
to tell us a lot about it if you take a
look at those
renders the thickness of the macbook is
barely larger than a usbc
port so that means that there will not
be hdmi
like we're expecting on the macbook pro
and speaking of that let's take a look
at the current macbook pro
the tapered design makes it a whole lot
thicker so just imagine the flat edge
where the usbc port sits to literally be
the thickness of the entire new
macbook that's absolutely insane
and i know that people are gonna lose
their minds when they see this macbook
in person
and based on that i actually have a
pretty good feeling that apple is gonna
call this
the macbook because this thing is
basically as thin
and small as it's ever gonna get and on
top of that mark german says that the
screen size will stay the same 13 inches
but the body size will get smaller to
fill in
the bezels so it's going to be smaller
than the current macbook air
so if they are ever going to be reusing
the simple
macbook name it's literally right now
or never because they won't be able to
make another macbook
much thinner or smaller than this one so
as far as the name
i'm still not 100 sure that it's gonna
be called the macbook
so we're just gonna have to wait and see
going further based on the renders
john prosser says that there's gonna be
one usb c port on each side of this
macbook
which is actually gonna be great because
it makes it so much more convenient
compared to currently having two ports
on one side and according to processor
his renders don't show the max safe
charging connector
but it might actually come with it in
the end with the final design but now
getting into some of the specs
the crazy thinness shows that apple's
probably gonna shoot for
two pounds for the marketed weight
matching the weight
of the 12-inch macbook that we used to
have before and if you think about the
retina 12-inch macbook
it came with a 40 watt hour battery
compared to the current
macbook air's 50 watt hours so for this
new macbook
apple could probably fit in a 40 to 45
watt hour battery
with little issue even in the thinner
size
since the wedge actually used to make it
very difficult
to fit in the battery cells now as far
as the chip that's going to be going
inside this macbook
i had a thought that apple might just
toss in the m1 chip again
but now that i think about it people are
gonna get confused between this
and the already existing m1 macbooks so
it needs to be known
as the m2 macbook and based on the
incredible thinness
of this new macbook there's no way
they're putting in a high performance
m1 chip that's going to be exclusive to
the pro models
so we are almost 100 likely getting
the m2 chip most likely with the same 8
core layout as the
m1 just more efficient and maybe a
little bit more powerful now as far as
some of the other specs
there's a chance that apple will
introduce 5g connectivity
like they did for the ipad pro but we
can't really know for sure just yet now
getting to the bottom of this new
macbook's case
john's renders show these new strips
instead of the four rubber feet that we
currently have
and here's why those strips look almost
identical to the ones from the bottom of
the current imac stands
and they give us two major advantages
first off
those strips will likely take up less
physical space inside of the actual
macbook air
and second it'll allow the macbook to
sit lower
or closer to the table instead of being
lifted up
on those four rubber feet so taking all
of that into account
this new macbook is basically going to
revolutionize the industry
all over again just like apple did with
the original macbook air
because there will be no windows laptop
anywhere near this thin in light
even when they eventually switch to
arm-based chips
which is going to happen sooner than you
think but with all of that said
the last major question that we have is
when this macbook is gonna get released
and i think i've narrowed it down to two
different dates
first off this redesign is a huge deal
so it deserves
its own dedicated time slot at an
official apple event
so keep that in mind both ming chi kuo
and digitimes
claimed that the new macbook redesign is
coming in 2022
but mark german on the other hand says
that it could come
as soon as later this year but he's
still
open to the possibility of a 2022
release date so in my mind
if it does come earlier it'll happen in
either october or november
whenever apple hosts their fall event
but if it happens next year
i think it's gonna happen in march at
their march event
since i think that the april spring
loaded event was a one-off thing
that they will no longer be repeating
next year and i don't think it'll come
any later than that because john prosser
has already seen an image of all of this
macbook air's prototype parts
all laid out like this image and i find
it hard to believe that apple will wait
a
full year and a half until late 2022
to release this macbook if it's already
got a prototype like that so between the
fall of this year and
march of next year it all depends on
when apple is going to be revealing
the 14 and 16 inch macbook pros if they
actually do reveal them at wwdc
a month from now then there's actually a
chance that we could see this new
m2 macbook this fall since that would
give us a few months in between the
release
of the m1x ship and the m2 chip but if
that doesn't happen and those 14
and 16 inch pros come this fall i'm
leaning towards a march release date for
this new
m2 macbook since it'll allow people to
focus
on the m1x pros for a few months before
the m2 chip is released
but then again who knows we might
actually be getting
it this year which would definitely be
awesome so there you guys have it those
were my thoughts on these new renders
from john prosser
and if you totally disagree with my
speculations go ahead and comment down
below
but if you enjoyed this video click that
circle about to subscribe for more like
this one
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in
the next video